foreign foreign
[Applause]
Brigade
complementations
Brazil
or this president is
European
universities
foreign
contemporary
police
foreign
impressions
the population
um
International
message
associated
foreign
European
journals the police from the passage
properties
Brazilian
nurses in places
foreign
on the line is
Europe
estabilities
foreign
thoughts
[Applause]
questions
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
water
and thank you so much for hosting me at
the national Confederation of Industry
indeed for over 80 years now
you have been not only
the voice of the Brazilian industry
but also a powerful Bridge across the
Atlantic
I know for example that you have
recently Taken part in the industry show
in my hometown in Germany the industry
fair and exchanges like this
are the backbone of the old friendship
between Europe
and Brazil
our countries are linked they are linked
not only by countless Family Ties
they're shaped by centuries of migration
between the two shores of the Atlantic
our cultures are also tied together
the Brazilian influence on Europe is
immense
think just about Oscar nimaya
or jilberto Jill
or the famous
and of course our economic ties
are strong
there is a long history
of mutual beneficial trade
Europe is the second largest destination
for Brazilian Goods
Brazil is the First Source
of agri-food products for Europe
and where there is trade
of course there is also investment
for decades Europe has been the first
foreign investor in Brazil
Europe has powered up the Brazilian
economy investing in raw materials and
food but also as you know in the heavy
industry in the car manufacturing
but interestingly
recently increasingly
in renewable energy and clean tech
just take this example
for almost two years now
Brazil and Europe have been connected by
Ella link
Ella link is the high-speed data cable
it runs over 6 000 kilometers on the
bottom of the Atlantic
between Brazil and Europe
and because of it
new data centers and new business to
business connections are just
mushrooming at both ends of the cable
in the mid-20s
century
Europeans used to call Brazil
do futuro
and today I would at the beginning like
to celebrate all the people
and the Business Leaders like you
who make the special partnership between
us come to life
every day obrigada
[Applause]
yet I believe there is much potential in
our partnership that is untapped
and now is the time to Breathe new life
into it
I believe that our mutual interest in
our partnership has never been stronger
than today
both for Brazil and for Europe
just look at the world around us it is
becoming more conflictual
more competitive
for decades
both Europe and Latin America
have been an integral part
of building a world order based on rules
with the United Nations system at its
core
Brazil was there
present at the creation
of the United Nations in San Francisco
and Brazil was the first country on
Earth
to ratify the U.N Charter
the very first words
of the UN Charter
proclaim the determination of the
peoples of the United Nations
to save succeeding Generations from the
scourge of War
unfortunately
war and conflict have not been
eliminated from our planet
when Russia
a nuclear armed
permanent member of the Securities
Council of the United Nations
sent its tanks over the border of
Ukraine last year
to conquer its Sovereign neighbor
this was simply a war of choice
and a direct strike on our International
order
the United Nations Charter that we all
depend on
since the beginning of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine
I have been in Kiev several times
I was in butcher
I saw the mass Graves
I saw the body bags aligned
I saw the scars from missiles
sent to terrorized civilians
destroying homes
hospitals
schools Kindergartens
of course we want peace
and no one more than the ukrainians
themselves
but it must be a just peace
it must be a piece that upholds the
principles of the U.N Charter
and enshrined in the U.N Charter
is the sovereignty
and the territorial Integrity of each
and every country
and therefore it must uphold the
ukrainians people's right
to be the masters of their own future
president zelenski
has come forward with a peace formula
every one of his ten points is based on
the principles of the U.N Charter
or U.N resolutions
and he has invited countries around the
world
to join and to build on that peace
formula
so our starting point for peace
should be the rules-based order
which we must fight to defend
and the people of Ukraine deserve and
end to their suffering
this war matters to everyone
who cares about upholding the rules
that International System is built upon
but it also matters to Brazil and Europe
on another reason
it sheds the light
on the importance of trading with
partners that you trust
for too long Europe relied on energy
imports from an unreliable country
before the war
we were heavily dependent on Russian
fossil fuels
then with the beginning of the war
Russia tried to Blackmail us and cut 80
percent
of its pipeline gas supplies to Europe
within eight months
that triggered a massive energy crisis
and you can imagine
that Breaking Free from our dependency
on Russian fossil fuels was really
costly
but it was worth it
we have
replaced those gas Imports in record
time
what have we done
we're first of all Diversified a way to
trusted partners
like for example Norway
secondly Europeans have saved 20 percent
of their energy consumption during last
winter
it was a cold winter but it was worth it
but most importantly
because we needed it we invested
massively into renewable energy
and last year despite the war
for the very first time we produced more
electricity
from Sun and wind
than from gas
and as Renewables are homegrown
this is not only good for our planet
but this is also good for Europe's
security of energy Supply
challenge we all face is the same both
in Brazil
and in Europe
at times of increasing Global risks
due to war
but also to climate change
and to great power competition
we all have to de-risk our supply chains
and for this we need reliable partners
friends who share our values
and whom we can truly trust
and few Partners around the world are as
like-minded as democracies in the
Americas and in Europe
therefore during this visit to Brazil
I would like to focus in particular
on three priority sectors to relaunch
oral partnership
the first is clean growth
the second sector is the human dimension
of the digital Revolution
and the third one is of course a more
just and prosperous international trade
let me begin with a first that is clean
growth
you may have heard about the so-called
European green deal
we want to reach climate neutrality by
2050.
we have cast this goal in law
we see this as Europe's New Growth
strategy
if we master
global warming it will only be possible
through Innovation we know that
so those who decarbonize early and smart
will have a competitive advantage
because cutting emissions
and protecting our climate and our
planet
is the new imperative
so those will have a head start
that innovate and that protect at the
same time and we see in Europe
the clean transition this Innovation for
clean transition as a massive
opportunity
for economic growth
I see that Brazil
is embarking on a similar path
president Lula has promised to reach Net
Zero deforestation
in Amazonia by 2030
and that can be very good news
not only for the planet
but for the local economy too
because European investors
are ready to chip in
they are ready to chip in with
contribution to the Amazon fund
they are ready to chip in with new
investment program for the Amazon basin
as part of our global gateway
infrastructure initiative
global gateway
is our new 300 billion investment plan
for sustainable Investments across the
world so not in Europe but across the
world actually I saw it there that you
have flagged it
global gateway
is
the plan
with which we are happy to announce here
today
that we are almost doubling our
financing for this project of global
gateway in Latin America and the
Caribbean
the European Union for example will make
10 billion euros available which on top
will have the private investment from
Europe and on top we'll have the
contributions of Our member states
in other words we are ready to finance
for example sustainable Forest
management
local Supply chains of course as well as
clean energy infrastructure
like hydrogen production and I'll come
later to that one
the difference is
that Global gateways Investments
will be sustainable
not only for the environment
but also for our partners finances
and for the local communities
it is a transparent
and value-based offer
we want the added value to stay with the
local communities
we want a long-term partnership
not a quick fix
we want a long-term partnership based on
trust and confidence
and take hydrogen
Brazil has an unlimited potential
for renewable for renewable energy
green hydrogen here
can be much much cheaper
than hydrogen from non-renewable sources
and you have already started producing
it
mostly actually thanks to technology
made in Europe and you are now building
three ports
that would allow Brazil
to export clean hydrogen to the world
now let's work on this together
because we Europeans we have set
ourselves the goal
of importing
10 million tons of renewable hydrogen
every year by 2030.
so we are interested
in a reliable partner
we are interested in long-term trust and
confidence
we are ready to invest in the whole
value chain of Renewables
of renewable energy and renewable
hydrogen in Brazil
whether it is from the production of
renewable electricity
or its conversion into clean hydrogen
even up to the production of green steel
that will be the end product of it and
the shipping infrastructure
there are up to 2 billion euros waiting
for being invested right now in
renewable energy
and Energy Efficiency
so together
we can build a transatlantic Market
for clean hydrogen
as reliable and equal partners
in other words let's join forces to save
the planet and to grow our economies
the second priority sector I would like
to address is the digital
in recent years we built a physical
infrastructure
to connect Europe and Latin America
now the next step is
to bring the same high-speed connections
to all counters of this beautiful
country
with more cables but also with more 5
and 6G connections that can reach the
most remote areas in Brazil
and we are also working to give you
access
to Europe's world-class satellite
systems for navigation and Earth
observation
and then there is another kind of
infrastructure
that is beyond optic fiber and antennas
Beyond optic fibers and antennas our
companies also need
similar rules and regulations
that allow for the free flow of data you
all know that
and here Brazil and Europe are truly
like-minded
we both want people and business
that can enjoy the same rights
online
as they do offline
Brazil and Europe are already very
similar in their laws and their on their
personal data protection we are
like-minded we share the same values
so we have now the opportunity to work
together
on for example regulating big platforms
on ensuring that all companies have
equal access to the market you know the
problem of the big Gatekeepers we don't
want that
we want the small and medium Enterprises
also to have a chance to access the
market freely
we have the chance together Europe and
Brazil as setting clear guard rails for
artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence has enormous
potential and opportunities but
it has also quite some risks and there
needs to be a decent regulation
and as we share so many values
why not join forces here
because if we align our rules
we would first and foremost
provide all our users
with better protections
but we would also create massive new
opportunities for Brazilian and European
businesses
to reach almost 700 million people
million consumers on both sides of the
Atlantic
and this leads me to my third and final
point on trade
trade between our regions
yes
the European Union and mercosul
are already very close trading partners
but you all know here in the room
there's still many obstacles that
curtail our trade flows
and the potential of our relationship
we have been discussing you said it a
trade deal for two decades now
it is the largest
and the most ambitious trade deal both
of us has have ever negotiated
and now finally
we are close to the finishing lines
I think it is time that we cross it now
the Finishing Line
it is time that we finalize and conclude
the Mercury agreement
president Lula and I today have both
committed that we want to conclude it as
soon as possible the latest by the end
of this year
[Applause]
and you know as well as me that it has
many benefits first of all it will give
our companies new opportunities to scale
up that is important
let me give you a few examples
trade between Europe and Canada
has grown by two-thirds in five years
only because of our trade deal and the
same
could happen here with mercosul
creating the largest InterContinental
free trade area in the world
second point it will give predictability
our agreement will set clear standards
for workers rights Environmental
Protection sustainable Supply chains
this means
that consumers will trust the products
they buy
and companies will have full clarities
on the rules of the game
as I said Europe and Latin America share
already the same values
with this trade deal
we will become ever more reliable
partner to one another
and the third element
of course it will attract more
investment
our supply chains will become more
integrated
more competitive and thus more
attractive for investors
and with new Investments Marco Sewell
will have the chance to move up the
value chain
so this Trade Agreement will not end 20
years of negotiations it will start a
whole new chapter in our economic
relationship and in our friendship
ladies and gentlemen
I have come to Brazil as my first stop
on a tour
through Latin America
our two regions have strong ties
but we are not yet making full use of
our combined potential
together we Face a world of Shifting
geopolitical forces of climate change
and technological transformation
together we should combine our strength
to defend our common interests and find
Solutions
to the global challenges that we face
that is our ambition for reinforcing our
relationship with Brazil
and for our relationship with the Latin
American Caribbean regions
we want to take this ambition
to the EU Latin America and Caribbean
Summit that takes place next month in
Brussels
I think this Summit will offer a golden
opportunity to launch an ambitious and
forward-looking agenda an agenda that
will renew our political links but of
course also grow our economic ties and
of course strengthen the bonds that do
exist between our peoples
together we can uphold I'm deeply
convinced
the international rules-based order
and the United Nations Charter
together we can reinforce our economic
resilience
and avoid over dependencies
together we can accelerate the
transition
to our common green and digital future
Brazil and Europe have been long time
friends
but I'm deeply convinced
that The Best Is Yet To Come thank you
very much
[Applause]